[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a la entrevista
de france 24 estamos en cúcuta al norte
de colombia y estamos con la mejor
tenista de américa latina- camila
usuario bienvenida muchísimas gracias
por la invitación hasta hace muy poquito
te conocíamos como maría camila usuario
porque cambiaste tu nombre la reunión me
sentía regañada se maneja a mi lado
obviamente me parece muy bonito pero acá
me lo han salido entonces me gusta más
camino y me digan camino bueno cambie
los horarios de ahora en adelante voy a
citar algunos de tus logros en este 2021
debut en un cuadro principal de grand
slam primera victoria en un cuadro
principal de grand slam primer título de
la w tea debut en los juegos olímpicos'
victoria ante una top 10 no ha estado
mal este año
sí la verdad que ha sido un año
bendecido han pasado cosas muy bonitas
que de alguna otra manera
soñaba o era una de las metas por este
año pero cuando ya se suceden o cuando
están se están realizando como que no
crees ha sido demasiado ya de todo esto
qué es lo que más te ha gustado aquí lo
que más anhelaba
no sé todo creo que lo que más poder
jugar un grand slam cuero principal de
grand slam
pues para eso era la idea entrada está
opción para poder clasificar y se dio un
envión en mi primera victoria de roland
garros clasifique pero también esperaba
que fuera mejor porque venía jugando muy
bien en el play y donde menos pensado y
wimbledon la sspe es una superficie que
uno nunca juega y ahí pero en todas las
victorias y yo no jugué en un estadio
contra una de las mejores del mundo fue
una experiencia increíble y su aval en
cádiz es el partido contra nadal en que
ese partido duro recuerdo porque yo
nunca había visto una jugadora que
aunque iba perdiendo son riera tanto te
lo pasas bien no
era así eran muchos sentimientos en el
momento porque no era que estuviera
feliz de estar aprendiendo pero pero
llegan a un punto y escuchar a la gente
hablar y de escuchar eso que uno sueña
que uno ve por televisión y estar
viviéndolo era como yo estaba como
soñando en el momento no bueno quiere
que me despertar no quería salir de la
cancha y quisiera terminar el partido y
yo era como que me enfoqué en un ratico
más y entre caminado espacios de la
toalla es un excelente increíble que te
dijo ello cuando termine el partido el
trigo algo en especial no me dejó que
tranquila y que ya llegó a llegar ahí yo
sé que ya aunque ya llega llega el
momento y pues yo le creo
su primer año señor en realidad fue el
2020 que fue el año de la pandemia tú
llegas a esta temporada después de haber
ganado el us open junior llegase a ser
la mejor junior del mundo pero esa
progresión se corta un poco por la
pandemia como este efecto eso
elche fue bastante difícil volver
pero inclusive en el principio el 2020
no fue muy muy muy bonito muy bueno
digamos porque por lo mismo tuve en el
10 open y que un al mundo juvenil pero
yo en mi casa está como que bueno la
transición va a ser tranquila voy a
llegar voy a empezar a ganar partidos y
va a seguir subiendo en el ranking ni
cerca yo jugará los torneos si yo no
pasaba en primeras rondas y bueno pues
sobre la pandemia obviamente y cuando
volví a jugar
estaba muy fuera de ritmo como que no me
sentía compitiendo o sea eso que es
entidad como que al principio que por lo
menos uno la emoción no de jugar no no
me estaba pasando
casi fue que me preparé ya para el 2021
y es este año fue maravilloso un año
maravilloso ya lo termina se terminaron
terminó con ese torneo en tenerife es al
final
abandona este porque tienes unas
molestias en el abdomen después de la
final físicamente cómo estás ahora
después de este año durante gran parte
de la temporada te vimos con ese vendaje
en el muslo izquierdo cómo estás gracias
a ella estoy bien
tuve reposo descanse unos días también
necesitaba como te comentaba hace un
rato descansar porque está ya me di
cuenta que tengo que trabajar mucho la
parte física para poder aguantar durante
todo el año la exigencia de los partidos
la exigencia los torneos
entonces si ahorita estoy bien gracias a
dios pero empezar a prepararme para el
año que viene la temporada la vas a
comenzar en australia me imagino en el
abierto australia si se va a ser vas a
estar en el último cuadro principal
número nesam que te falta ya los
pues tenemos llegada a australia fue
hace dos años
en el año 2020 y
me encantó porque es puede mostrarle
australia todo era increíble la
programación es como decorar de
reclasificación una vez la mera serán lo
máximo que yo deseaba a conectar el
cuadro principal este año jugamos en
dubai tendrá como que muy diferente muy
raro pero ahora este es el que viene a
tener la oportunidad jugarlo pues ya lo
que lo que no que en lo que deseaba hace
ya bastante tiempo entonces va a ser
bueno espero comprendió es que sea un
gran inicial finalmente les han dicho
algo ya les han notificado algo acerca
de si tienen que ser vacunados o no toda
esta polémica que ha habido están
haciendo reuniones y están hablando pues
con jugadores buenos directores todo el
tema el gobierno también ellos creo que
lo que no quiere que se va con todos
pero yo estoy vacunado pero hay
deportistas que prefieren no el precisó
están en cada quien no pero sí están
sant creo que de alguna manera
negociando para ver qué se puede hacer
para que éste se pueda jugar el torneo
tú prefieres que sea obligatorio que
haya
que haga falta vacunarse para jugar o te
hacen diferente pues no sé yo pienso que
no tanto tiempo que duramos encerrados
en un estado buscando pidiendo una
solución pidiendo no ayudar tantas cosas
feas que pasaron no lo que quería era
estar bien puede sentir seguro alguna
otra manera creo que la vacuna está
sentir eso no te bueno no sé como
software de tarjetas de crédito que pues
como que menos riesgo
entonces pues por mí que todos
quisiéramos vacunados pero pues cada
persona tiene una manera diferente de
pensar y los que no quieran pero no se
les puede ligar ya está cerca del top 50
en este año en el que tu objetivo era
estar en el top 100 cumpliste la meta
bastante bien de cara el próximo año que
meta tiene de se pensada
el año que viene y seguir mejorando
seguir creciendo en la parte turística
mental física todo lo que tenga que ver
conmigo también personal
y obviamente tengo métodos mucho más
altas pero ahorita no me quiero fijar en
el ranking en que tengo que pasar esto
tengo que quiero simplemente lugar
obviamente voy con la idea de ganar
torneos así que es llegar a torneos una
cosa dijo la otra sí que voy a pensar es
en eso en ir a ganar torneos grandes los
últimos seis grand slam del circuito
femenino los han ganado cinco jugadoras
distintas tres de ellas nunca habían
ganado un grand slam crees que en ese
momento el circuito femenino el nivel
está muy igualado sí exactamente creo
que
es bueno y a la vez no se logra dando
porque tienes el chance de jugar a
cualquiera
cualquiera entonces sí es muy igualado
puede pasar cualquier cosa tú lo que
pasó ahora con el dios open raducanu
desde cual ganó el torneo
sorpresa por leila también llegó a
finales
y varía mucho cambia mucho
igual por lo menos en ese momento
también era bueno cuando teníamos una
referente que eran selena que siempre se
mantuvo hasta ahorita siempre se mantuvo
ahí siendo lo mejor no como que no ha
cambiado mucho eso también sería bueno
chévere que tuviéramos una pues alguien
así a alguien más no se estable y
durante durante los años pero pero sí
igual creo que también bueno por hasta
las nuevas generaciones que vamos
subiendo porque pues tenemos chances es
una mezcla no porque siempre que un
referente casi que se atraen más
aficionados pero lo que tú dices para
ustedes como jugadoras que el nivel este
ha sido parejo abre más el abanico a la
hora de competir exacto
tú compartes equipo con robert farah y
juan sebastián cabal una de las mejores
parejas que hay en el mundo como su
relación con ellos
no pues robert y sedas son
grandes jugadores son buenas personas no
no comparto mucho con ellos o sea cuando
estamos haciendo en algunos torneos que
nos vemos y demás
a veces me escriben a veces les escribo
para obviamente ellos tienen mucha más
diferencia que yo en el circuito también
hacemos parte del equipo colsánitas
entonces es chévere tener pues como es
el referente también como de alguna otra
manera su ayuda porque están ahí y te
pueden aconsejar o sí o indicar más o
menos por un día
pero si los admiro obviamente y es muy
chévere tenerlos a ellos como
representantes del tenis en colombia son
los tres grandes referentes en este
momento del tenis colombiano ellos en
dupla como parejas y tú en singles en
este momento cómo te sientes en este
momento de representar a colombia en un
nivel tan alto de tenis es muy bonito es
muy importante para mí porque como te
decía de trabajo
mucho para esto muy duro durante muchos
años las personas están conociendo esta
extraña que empezaron a ver un poco más
de pronto bueno el líder no ven también
pero ahora como que bueno ya en el tema
del profesionalismo y eso pero han sido
muchos años de hay muchos
esfuerzos no hacía sacrificios porque me
encanta jugar al tenis así que eso pero
pero sí de muchos esfuerzos de mucho
trabajo mucha disciplina y ahora se
están dando los resultados entonces
causa mucha alegría mucha felicidad
poder lograr lo que es y lo grande
pasando al plano a plano personal tienes
un abuelo que jugó en el mundial de
fútbol del 62 tu padre juega fútbol tu
madre jugaba baloncesto ella es parte de
toda una familia de futbolistas y de
alto nivel
ya no sé ni por qué el tenis pero sí
toda toda mi familia deportista lo cual
es buenísimo porque siempre están
apoyándome y acompañándome pues en todo
el proceso ellos entienden lo que es
todo lo que se le ha quitado todos los
días tienen que todos los días una
terminada
cansadísimo que no se quiere mover que
no quiere saber la habitación que
siempre están pendientes también aparte
de la niña soy la menor yo soy la más
consentida
entonces es muy bonito tener a mi
familia que me entiendan y que me puedan
apoyar
viendo también un poco más acerca de ti
vi que toca el ukelele te quería
preguntar si te lo llevas a los torneos
y es una especie de terapia o si
simplemente no tienes tiempo para
tocarlo me retiré
a veces cuando pero no
es una pena
la guitarra es una guitarra también
de clases pero creo que hay talentos
para todos
yo soy intento me parece si a mí me
encanta aprender a todo yo me encanta
aprender cosas nuevas porque no tenga ni
idea y que no lo haga muy bien pero
solamente muestro el hecho de saber de
conocerme me llama la atención el
intento pero como éste siempre hay cosas
que se le facilitarán tanto a mí me
gusta me facilita tal vez los deportes
yo creería más que como un instrumento
ya cuando hay competición lo que haces
es me decía antes llevarte tu tablet y
ver series
y te ayuda para hacer más relajada en
esos momentos antes de las competiciones
sí sí la verdad
cuando estoy más relajada cuando estoy
más tranquila es donde cuando mejor
juego
porque no hay como que no me pongo tanta
presión
y al final es la que más me va mal la
más importante porque tú entra a la
cancha al final hay antiguas con la
rival pero también vas contra ti mismo
solo tienes que estar lo más tranquilo y
calmado posible entonces si cuando tenga
el tiempo un relajo estoy en como no en
otro plan pero como que si pensando en
de pronto en otras cosas
perfecto cambio la muchísimas gracias
por este tiempo te deseamos lo mejor
para estudian 2022 que arranque muy bien
en este open de australia muchísimas
gracias gracias por por el tiempo
elementos y por permitirme compartir un
poco de mi historia y yo no quiero
agradecer también a los colombianos y a
las personas que me han estado apoyando
durante este tiempo durante este año ha
sido un gran año para mí ha sido muy
especial importante como lo venía
diciendo entonces gracias por el apoyo y
espero me puedan seguir acompañando en
lo que se viene es seguro que sí
muchas gracias también como siempre a
ustedes quédense porque hay más mucho
más énfasis 24 y france 24 puntocom